et voilà c'était comme tu es belle avoir
20 ans en pays taliban un documentaire
réalisé par Solen chalbon fiorityti
bonjour bonjour vous nous faites
l'honneur de participer à la Zone
d'Éducation documentaire et à vos côtés
on a la chance d'accueillir shakiba
Daoud bonjour bonjour vous êtes afghan
vous avez fui votre pays il y a 15 ans
euh aujourd'hui vous vous définissez
comme artiviste c'est avec l'art que
vous défendez la cause afghane euh
aujourd'hui et je le précise vous êtes
également interprète FARC pour l'OFPRA
c'est l'office France fr de protection
des réfugiés et à patride vous aider en
gros les réfugiés afghans à communiquer
avec les autorités françaises merci à
toutes les deux d'être là voilà pour les
les présentations enfin presque parce
que c'est aujourd'hui la classe de 3ei
du collège les Prunets à Viliers surm
qui va vous poser des questions bonjour
les élèves bonjour alors vous avez
énormément travaillé sur ce film je sais
que vous avez plein de réflexions plein
de questions à poser à nos à nos deux
invités juste avant je voulais savoir si
vous vous connaissiez la situation de
l'Afghanistan avant de regarder ce
documentaire dis-moi Saï oui je la
connaissais déjà ouais à travers quoi à
travers un documentaire qui était passé
sur BFM TV vers 201728 d' ok qu'est-ce
que vous saviez de l'Afghanistan en gros
vous saviez que c'était ça se passait
comme ça comme ce que vous avez vu dans
le documentaire oui dis-moi non pas du
tout moi je savais pas du tout tu savais
pas et vous les filles vous saviez que
c'était comme ça en Afghanistan je m'en
doutais tu t'en doutais oui Gabriel ça
t'a fait quoi toi de voir ces images c
un peu touchant parce qu'on a pas
l'habitude de voir ça tous les jours
ouais et ça arrive souvent dans d'autres
pays que le nôre donc on n'est pas trop
conditionné à avoir des images comme ça
HM à un moment donné on la prend alors
il s'avère qu'aujourd'hui la situation a
malheureusement encore évolué et pas
dans le bon sens mais au moment où sont
tourné ces images il est question que
les universités donc que les étudiants à
l'université soient séparés fillees
garçon euh ça vous est-ce que vous
imaginez vous le collège avec les filles
d'un côté et les garçons de l'autre
Kaba dis-moi ce que tu en penses moi
franchement je sais pas vraiment à quoi
ça peut ressembler mais en Afghanistan
enfin moi je savais ce qui se passait en
Afghanistan mais je savais pas vraiment
ce qui se passait précisément
précisément voilà et si et si le collège
il était séparé avec les garçons d'un
côté les filles de l'autre ça te ferait
quoi ah je sais pas franchement ce
serait une bonne chose tu pense
peut-être pas h qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez vous les filles d'orquestre
dis-moi tu en penses quoi toi bah ça
fera ça ferait bizarre ouaisê séparé ok
qu'est-ce que vous avez pensé du
parcours de ces de ces deux jeunes
filles naviguer dans plusieurs pays et
tout la situation familiale tout ça
ouais ça forge le respect on va
maintenant passer à à vos questions et
on commence tout de suite avec toi
Dorcas j'auris une question pour Solen
chalevon qu'est-ce qui vous a donné
envie de tourner en reporire sur ce
sujetl et pourqui pas sur un autre
pays
alors d'abord je dois dire que ce sujet
je l'ai pas fait toute seule je l'ai
coréalisé je l'ai pas réalisé toute
seule je l'ai coréalisé avec une de mes
très grande pote qui s'appelle margaot
margaot Ben et c'est une partie de la
réponse c'est parce que moi j'ai j'ai
travaillé en Afghanistan très longtemps
j'ai habité là-bas pendant la guerre et
ce qui permettait aussi de faire des
films de ce genre c'était d'être avec
une amie quand même on sent toujours
plus fort quand on est deux d'ailleurs
c'était on était deux amis qui filmait
deux amis euh on a fait des sujets
franchement beaucoup plus compliqués que
celui-là mais la raison pour laquelle
celui-là il nous a plu c'est qu'elles
étaient très proches de nous en fait le
salon de beauté vous avez dans le film
il était en bas de chez moi à caboula
donc ma moi j'habitais dans une tour et
enfin j'habitais d'abord dans une maison
et puis les talibans sont arrivés ils
ont pris l'Afghanistan ils ont confisqué
notre maison et donc on a déménagé dans
un immeuble et en fait dans C cet
immeuble il donnait sur un salon de
beauté on voyait toujours plein de
jeunes femmes qui en sortaient et en
fait quand les talibans sont venus on
s'est mis à regarder les filles très
différemment parce qu'on avait très très
peur qu'elles disparaissent et
d'ailleurs elles se sont mis à
disparaître et là vous voyez dans le
film Le salon qui existe je sais pas si
vous avez regardé mais entretemps les
talibans ils ont fermé tous les salons
de beauté euh du pays et donc on a
pressenti avec mon ami margaot que ça ça
allait s'arrêter parce que les
connaissant assez bien ils allaient
péter un câble euh de voir des filles
encore voilà vivre librement vous avez
vu comment elles sont inérieur du salon
ell s'habille comme vous en fait les
filles elles ont votre âge et donc ça
les talibans il il le ils le savaient
bien sûr ils entendaient la musique à
l'intérieur de ces salons il voyait bien
que les filles elles venaient
progressivement avec leurs petites sœur
avec leur cousines et que ça devenait
vraiment un refuge de femme donc on
s'est dit faut vite vite tourner parce
que bientôt ça n'existera plus et et
c'est ce qui est arrivé on continue avec
Gena j'ai deux questions pour Soline
est-ce que vous avez dû respecter les
lois du pays et est-ce que vous avez
tourné dans la
clandestinité tu veux dire les lois du
pays les lois des talibans quoi la loi
des talibans d'accord
euh non pas trop j'ai pas trop respecté
la loi des talibans parce que en fait la
loi là enfin la loi ça il y a tellement
de lois il y a tellement d'interdits
pour les femmes que je dirais pas que je
l'ai respecté mais je dirais pas que je
l'ai pas respecté non plus parce que
shakiba c'est ça mieux que moi ce qui
est terrible en Afghanistan c'est que
elle et moi si on va là-bas je vais
avoir beaucoup plus de droits que
shakiba parce que shakiba elle est
afghane donc ils vont se jeter sur elle
alors que moi je vais quand même je vais
avoir un certain privilège de femmes
blanches d'abord mais aussi du fait que
je sois ni afghan ni musulmane
donc moi je peux flirter avec la loi je
vais prendre beaucoup moins de risque
que si ma sœur afghane elle flirte avec
la loi quant au tournage dans la
clandestinité oui alors là c'est
complètement en fait on utilisait la
bourka et le nikab pour cacher les enfin
j'allais dire les caméras on avait même
pas vraiment des caméras on avait des
boîtiers enfin comme je vois qu'il y a
ça ici on avait les voitiers qu'on caché
sous le sous la bourka et sous le nicab
et d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que c'est il
y a des parties qui qui tremblent
beaucoup et qui sont assez mal tournées
parce que vous avez vu autour de vous
ils utilisent des des pieds pour pour
poser les caméras nous on pouvait pas
vraiment rentrer avec ça donc c'était
toujours un peu à la rche quoi mais euh
on s'est pas fait é choper
quoi achelet j'ai une question pour
Soline euh quelles étaient vos peurs en
tant que journaliste et quelles ont été
vos conditions de travail
euh alors mais ma peur en tant que
journaliste en fait à l'époque on avait
pas trop peur euh quand les talibans ils
arrivent tout le monde est pétrifié
pétrifié ensuite on se rend compte qu'en
fait ils sont peut-être moins durs que
ce qu'on imagine donc on passe comme ça
quelques semaines quelques mois à se
dire bon peut-être que ils sont pas
aussi PIR que ce qu'on imaginait qu'ils
laisseront les filles travailler qui
laisseront les filles marcher dans la
rue le visage découvert qui laisseront
les filles aller à l'école
et moi j'ai un peu commencé à tourner
dans cette un peu à commencé à tourner
dans cette zone là je sais pas si vous
vous rappelez il y a un moment où les
filles sont dans le parc donc dans le
parc en fait la la scène du parc elle
répond à ta question je sais pas si vous
avez fait gaffe mais dans non vous allez
pasit dites-moi que vous avez pas fait
gaffe à ça mais franchement le parc
c'est extrêmement mal filmé oh non ça
tremble c'est comme ça c'est immonde on
voit rien enfin et ça c'est ouais ben
merci les gars mais donc ça c'est mon
œuvre alors quand même je sais un peu
filmer mais parce que justement c'est la
première fois que il y avait un taliban
qui s'avançait vraiment vers moi euh
dans un espace fermé et où là j'avais
pas moi je savais très bien qu'il me
ferait pas grand-chose au début je vous
dis les talibans surtout les filles
comme moi ils comprenaient pas très bien
ce qu'on venait de faire ils étaient pas
très ça ça après ça s'est beaucoup durci
mais j'étais terrifié pour les filles
qui étaient devant moi avec ces deux
hommes qui s'approchent vous voyez la
scène dont je parle et donc et vous
voyez en fait il les laissent c'est
intéressant d'ailleurs elles sont là on
a peur qu'est-ce qu'on fait on bouge on
bouge pas on parle pas et donc moi
j'étais dans cet état-là aussi face à la
caméra donc j'ai eu des peurs comme ça
euh pour les filles pas vraiment pour
moi on poursuit avec Gabriel question
pour Madame shakiba Daoud comment et
dans quel but les talibans sont-ils
arrivés au pouvoir en fait je pense que
arrivver des talibans en Afghanistan
dépend de plusieurs facteurs euh on sait
très bien que les Américains sont
arrivés en Afghanistan dans les années
2001 2002 après la chute de premier euh
période taliban euh enfin tu c'est très
bien peut-être que il y avait des tours
de Wall Street Center qui étai explosé à
cause de Ben Laden après les Américains
cherchaient Ben Laden et il Savit qu'il
s'étaient caché en Afghanistan donc ils
ont attaqué l'Afghanistan l'armée de
autan où le coalition sont arrivés en
Afghanistan et après ils ont instauré un
gouvernement provisoire qui a duré 20 20
ans à peu près et pendant cette période
là les talibans n'ont jamais AB Ronné ce
qui a fait que le pays n'a jamais vécu
dans la sécurité totale et petit à petit
quand les gens enfin c'est-à-dire que
les Occidentaux ont compris qu'il
n'arrivent pas vraiment à étouffer les
talibans
les comment dire les éliminer
complètement ils ont commencé à
renégocier et devant eux c'était les
États-Unis c'est-à-dire que les
États-Unis ont investi énormément en
Afghanistan pour les éimination de
terrorisme mais au final au bout de 20
ans de lutte contre le terrorisme en
Afghanistan contre les talibans ils ont
décidé de négocier contre les mêmes
terroristes avec qui ils étaient en
train de lutter et il enfin c'était en
2020 si je me trompe pas c'était en
février 2020 qu'ils ont commencé les
accords de DOA notamment chez la
communauté afghan on dit que le
gouvernement s'est rendu c'est-à-dire
que on a demandé aux armées afghanes de
ne pas s'opposer de ne pas ouvrir le
faut de ne pas se battre contre les
talibans h pour poursuivre justement
Kaba ta question j'ai une question pour
Madame Daoud euh qu'est-il arrivé à
l'ancien gouvernement ENF en Afghanistan
c'était Ashraf Gani Ahmad zï lui il a
décidé euh de de s'enfuir enfin dès la
le premier jour de la chute il a quitté
l'Afganistan avec l'avion présidentielle
et quelques valises de dollars et il est
parti s'installer dans un des pays
arabes je pense que c'était à Dubaï ou
ou à Bahrein si je me trompe pas oui et
enfin il a essayé de de de trouver un
refuge pour lui pour se cacher et il
pensait rendre service à ses frères
pasachtoun comme le pays a été gouverné
pendant plusieurs générations par des
présidents qui sont tous de même ethnie
donc il il était à la fois fier et pas
pas trop F de lui est-ce que depuis
l'arrivée des talibans les conditions de
vie des personnes pauvres se sont
dégradées oui bien sûr alors depuis
l'arrivée de taliban le le système
financier ou économique de pays s'est
complètement effondré euh les gens ont
dû partir tellement ils avaient peur ils
ont abandonné euh enfin leur métier euh
et beaucoup de pendant plusieurs
semaines voir les premiers mois beaucoup
d'entreprises ont fermé parce que ils
avaient fait des réformes parce que tout
toutes les métiers ou en tout cas corps
administratif de gouvernement devrait
s'adapter à la charia qui est la loi
islamique donc il faudrait que tout ça
se passe par le filtre de la religion et
cetera donc c'est pour ça qu'ils ont
fermé euh les universités donc les
professeurs ne pouvaient pas aller à
l'université enseigner et beaucoup de
femmes ont dû partir abandonner leur
métier notamment tout ce qui est le
corps magistral par exemple parce que
les femmes n'avaient pas le droit de
d'être au magistrat en Afghanistan ils
ont pas le droit à travailler dans aucun
métier en ce moment les médecins et tout
ça il y a quelques métiers où les femmes
peuvent toujours travailler si je me
trompe pas sol tu peux me corriger par
exemple les sagesfemmes parce que on a
toujours des femmes qui qui donnent
naissance aux enfants donc on a besoin
des des femmes voilà des professeurs par
exemple
euh voilà pour les petites ou pour les
écoles primaires jusqu'à 6e classe elles
ont droit de enseigner mais sinon euh
tout de suite le système économique
s'est effondré les gens étaient obligés
de trouver d'autres alternatives par
exemple vendre leurs organes ou vendre
leurs petites filles leurs enfants ils
vont pas tout de suite vendre les
garçons parce que
euh en Afghanistan il y a des coutumes
des traditions les mariag arrangés
existe depuis la nuit des temps donc ils
ont les gens ont préféré de échanger
leurs enfants leurs jeunes filles euh au
lieu enfin pour gagner un petit peu
d'argent et nourrir le reste de membres
de leur famille h Ivana on t'écoute je
voulais savoir où les équipes elles
étaient logées sur place les les équipes
alors les équipes c'est c'est deux
personnes c'est c'est margaot et margaot
et moi moi c'est un pays avec lequel
j'ai une grande histoire très longue
donc j'ai j'ai j'avais mon appartement
là-bas ma chambre du coup ma coloque
donc c'était très facile pour nous on
continue avec Gena est-ce que le but des
taliban est d'exterminer tous les
Afghans euh je pense
que quand on a envie de régner de
gouverner un pays on a besoin d'un
peuple sur qui régner donc si ils
exterminent les gens sur qui ils peuvent
gouverner mais ils ont envie que les
gens suivent pas par pas lettre par
lettre tout ce que eux il demandent donc
à mon avis ils ont besoin des gens et
aussi pour montrer que ils étaient
capables et qu'ils avaient raison euh de
vouloir euh conquérir le le pays HM on
continue avec Dorcas qui est juste là
alors j'aurais deux questions pour vous
Madame chalevon premièrement est-ce que
cela n'a pas été trop compliqué de
trouver des femmes qui n'avaient pas
peur des talibans et deuxièmement
quelles étaient les craintes des femmes
afghanes ayant participé au
documentaire
euh alors Sophia et negina les filles du
film vous voyez la première enfin non
c'est pas la première scène d'ailleurs
mais enfin elles ont franchement elles
ont pas peur de grand-chose euh c'est de
filles très très courageux et aussi
comme je pense toutes les jeunes filles
de de leur âge du monde entier elles
s'engrainent beaucoup l'une et l'autre
donc quand on voyait sopia toute seule
ou nigina toute seule on avait pas du
tout on voyait pas du tout les mêmes
filles quand elle cétait à deux elle se
elle se challengeait elle se voilà elle
se elle s'engrait quoi je sais pas
comment dire ça avec un mot français pas
voilà plus chic et euh et donc ça c'est
ça c'est en fait ça a l'air de rien mais
c'est très classique c'està-dire que
quand on est ensemble on est plus fort
on se sent plus fort donc nous on les a
pas du tout euh on les a pas du tout
pressurisé en fait elles adorait la
caméra et d'ailleurs c'est c'est
incroyable parce que elles sont là
maintenant donc Sophia elle a habité
longtemps chez moi à Paris et maintenant
elle travaille dans un salon à
châteauouge à Paris et et en fait céit
la même chose à Paris c'estàd qu'à Paris
elle me disait mais quand est-ce qu'on
me bon quand est-ce qu'on filme
d'ailleurs il y a plein de gens qui
l'ont filmé ici qui l'avit reconnu euh
euh et en fait elle elle a écrit un
livre ici enfin elle a très très envie
euh de prendre la lumière elle est
beaucoup de elle est comme beaucoup de
de d'afghan que j'ai rencontré en
Afghanistan c'est qu'elles ont vraiment
c'est une génération qui a utilisé les
réseaux sociaux euh en fait moi je c'est
que je vois parce que maintenant je suis
rentrée en France je vois en France
comment on parle des jeunes et des
réseaux sociaux c'est toujours dans la
critique euh et ça me frappe beaucoup
parce que moi je donc je viens d'un pays
enfin je viens je si tu me tu viens le
partager un petit peu avec moi j'étais
dans un pays très longtemps où en fait
les réseaux sociaux sont pour les jeunes
une vraiment une fenêtre sur le monde la
seule façon pour des Afghans de votre
âge aujourd'hui de parler avec leurs
amis la seule il en existe pas d'autres
ou alors vous allez à la maternité vous
avez pas de raison d'accoucher là la
seule façon pour elle de parler avec
leurs amis c'est les réseaux sociaux il
y a pas d'autres lucarnees il y a pas
d'autres fenêtres il y a pas d'autres
possibilités et grâce à Dieu les les
talibans sont pas encore en capacité de
couper internet donc en fait les filles
c'estes réseaux tous autant qu'ils soit
c'est-à-dire alors ça c'est pas
forcément ça arrive pas forcément dans
le même ordre que dans cette partie du
monde mais elles sont beaucoup sur
TikTok sur snap sur insta en fait les
réseau leur leur non seulement leur
permettent de communiquer entre elles
mais aussi en fait les réseaux leur
offrent ell voient ce qui se passe dans
le reste du monde donc elles se disent
mais en fait c'est cool de moi aussi je
peux faire ça moi aussi je peux voilà je
peux avoir une communauté je peux parler
à mes fans je peux me regarder dans la
glace je peux danser voilà et donc en
fait là encore les les réseaux sociaux
ils déclenchent chez cette jeunesse là
un sursaut de liberté et donc sopia et
ngina elles adoraient ça ça aussi c'est
votre génération vraiment les selfies de
se regarder de se trouver jolie de avez
vu elles sont tout à fait voilà
s'assumer en corps et âme s'exprimé et
le visage parce que le visage ça l'air
de rien mais le visage il est interdit
en Afghanistan là les talibans ils le
suppriment le visage moi j'ai pas le
droit de montrer mon mon visage quand je
vais là-bas donc en fait d'exposer son
visage à ce point-là c'est aussi c'est
devenu d'abord c'est devenu très très à
la mode hein donc il y a beaucoup
d'Afghanes qui le font et je vois la
même chose en fait chez les jeunes ici
c'estàd que elles vont se grossir les
lèvres elles vont se mettre des immenses
yeux 50000 filtres de paillettes moi je
sais pas combien de photos il y a de
mois en fait filtré en Afghanistan avec
des moustaches et des machins voilà
c'est vraiment elles en fait elles
adorent elles adorent ça et euh et en ça
j'ai c'est pour ça que moi ça M
intéresse beaucoup les réseaux sociaux
dans ce genre de paysl c'est parce que
c'est c'est vraiment devenu une arme
politique maintenant les filles elles
ont envie d'être vu elles ont envie
d'être belles donc si tu veux elles
avaient envie de faire le film elles
avaient envie d'être dedans et dans le
salon de beauté c'était pas pareil parce
que j'avais pas passé autant de temps
avec les deux et et ma Coréal Margot non
plus mais dans le salon d'abord on
savait qu'on allait flouter les visages
et puis moi je encore une fois tu vois
je fais pas ce qu'on appelle dans mon
jargon d' news c'est dire que je dis pas
tu vois je pas arrivé en mode hello
envoyé spécial j'ai 48 he pour faire ce
truc euh voilà voilà après je repars là
on avait le temps en fait on habitait
au-dessus donc parfois on venait avec la
caméra on la posait il se passait rien
les fill s'était pas dans l'ambiance ou
alors il y avait des clientes qui
étaient relou enfin qui étaient pas à
l'aise avec elle et tout donc elle
disait non mais c'est pas le bon moment
vas-y repars on en profitait on restait
là on se faisait les ongles on remontait
enfin c'était on avait vraiment le temps
et quand tu as le temps tu instaes un
rapport de confiance avec les gens qui
font qu'à un moment il il se il se
laisse aller quoi et ce qu'on a juste
dit là avec les filles c'est que moi je
voulais qu'il VO les images les gens de
partir euh parce que c'est des images ça
ça l' encore une fois ça a l'air de rien
pour vous mais shakiba pourrait vous le
dire des filles qui dansent devant une
caméra c'est enfin je l'ai pas vu en
fait ça se fait pas du tout c'est très
très ouais c'était très d'ailleurs cé un
vrai cadeau à me faire parce que ça se
fait pas du tout du tout dans la culture
afghane elle pourra avoir des problèmes
pour le coup vraiment grave euh en
faisant ça mais il y a eu
progressivement une forme de vraiment
une forme de relâchement et après j'ai
montré les images on a on a montré les
images avant de partir on était sûr de
flouter on avait pas dit dans quel salon
on était dans la ville ni dans quelle
ville d'ailleurs et du coup et du coup
il y a pas eu de problème pour revenir
justement sur sur cette liberté
incroyable et ce là cette pulsion de vie
de ces femmes je voudrais revenir 2
secondes sur une séquence qui moi m'a
particulièrement marqué c'est la
manifestation
Mar
marine
est-ce que vous vous êtes dit mais elles
sont totalement inconsciente dorc
qu'est-ce que tu en as pensé toi à ce
momentl je me suis surtout dit queah en
fait elles étent fortes genre de faire
de faire ça alors qu'elle savait que bah
il y aurait peut-être des conséquences
et je pense qu'il y en a eu oui et en
vrai j'étais
plutôt je sa pas comment dire mais en
tout cas je les ai trouvé fortes ok les
garçons vous les avez trouvé comment
dis-moi sa trouv ça très risqué de faire
ça parce que il y a des conséquences
avec ça les conséquences on les voit on
les voit à ce moment-là il y a un
taliban qui arrive et qui dit je ne sais
plus si c'est an nigina il dit an nigina
couvre ta tête espèce de puttin oui
dis-moi oui je me rappelle ça t'a marqué
ça t'a choqué ben ça se fait pas enfin
c'est n'importe quoi benah j'avais de la
peine pour elle parce que elle est pas
obligée de se couvrir si elle veut pas
du coup
ben je vois pas de quoi il se met enfin
elle fait ce qu'elle veut personne n' eu
peur moi j'ai eu peur moi je vous le dis
moi j'ai eu peur pour elle pourquoi
avoir peur parce que c'est il était du
côté des taliban du coup elle savait
très bien que il y avait forcément une
personne qui allait lui dire ça elle est
forte parce que moi peut-être que
j'aurais pas eu le courage de faire ça
d'accord on continue avec Asia qui est
juste là j'ai une question pour Solen
est-ce que l'une des personnes du
tournage a été arrêtée non il y a
personne qui qui a été arrêté mais il y
a eu des des très gros coups de stress
parce que nigina elle a disparu pendant
le tournage nigina elle a fui en
Allemagne alors qu'on avait pas terminé
de tourner et elle a fui enfin n on
était vraiment mais bon en même temps on
fait ce métier pour ça on fait ça on se
fait ce métier pour que le réel en fait
vous vous attrape et vous dépasse mais
du coup on était là avec sopia qui est
son voilà sa bfff quoi et qui se
retrouve avec sa copine disparue euh et
donc ça on s'est beaucoup inquiété pour
elle parce que ça mis du temps avant de
savoir où elle était donc on avait très
très peur que ça soit lié au film Ctait
peut-être je sais pas 40 % de notre
notre temps de notre disponibilité
mentale c'était de se dire attention
attention attention euh on peut pas se
retrouver avec une catastrophe pareil
d'une des filles qui se fait embarquer à
cause de nous quoi parce que le problème
c'est l'Afghanistan c'est pas du tout
que les talibans le problème c'est ça
quoi c'est les gens qui parlent les gens
qui dénoncent euh les gens qui ont des
comptes à rendre les gens qui ont vous
savez si vous arrivez à la fin de la
guerre à la fin de la guerre la guerre
ça a fait beaucoup de mal à plein de
gens et pour beaucoup ils ont très très
envie de se venger et eux ça ils ont
rien à voir avec les talibans et donc
nous on avait très peur qu'à l'intérieur
du salon il y ait une femmees qui
dénonce qui parl vous avez vu il y a du
monde dans le salon il y a toutes les
générations il y avait il y a des femmes
très très éloignées des filles habillées
comme ça et Machin et donc ça c'était
vraiment ce qu'on craignait le plus
parce que ça on pouvait pas vraiment
savoir ce que les gens avaient dans la
tête donc en fait on se fiait au feeling
des filles autour de nous quoi mais on
avait peur d'être dénoncé depuis
l'intérieur du salon ouais est-ce que
vous êtes rebellé sur place et comment
est-ce que vous avez résisté donc je me
suis inscrit à à l'université et j'ai
décidé de faire de l'art parce que je
pensais que cela me permettait de
imaginer de vivre autre chose que de de
m'enfermer soit à la maison ou d'avoir
un travail ou une vie ennuyeux je
m'ennuie très vite donc ça c'était
adapté à ma façon de voir le monde et
enfin une fois arrivé à l'université
j'ai fait la rencontre de troupe de
théâtre du soleil qui était venu à à
Kabou pour organiser un stage de théâtre
donc j'ai été acceptée comme comédienne
et j'ai commencé à faire du théâtre et
c'était voilà c'était pour la première
fois où je me sentais vraiment libre de
faire ce que je veux avec euh ma vie et
avec ma liberté c'est ce qui vous a
contraint aussi derrière à à partir ou
beaucoup de difficultés oui on a on a
monté une pièce de
théâtre une tartouff de Molière et on
l'a adapté à la société afghane euh donc
il y avait des mollas à la place de
clergé et voilà le prêtre euh ça n pas
plu au Taliban et ils nous
ont et même si c'était enfin à l'époque
de démocratie c'était en 2008 euh mais
on recevait quand même des lettres de
menace un de nos collègues a été victime
il a été euh enfin tué par des talibans
et et nous on a senti qu'on était
vraiment en danger on a décidé de partir
et de quitter le pays on continue avec
Mona est-ce que c'était plus dur pour
les personnes pauvres d'obtenir un visa
euh oui oui euh dans les pays comme
l'Afghanistan il y a beaucoup de
corruption c'est-à-dire que le système
fait que tout le monde s'habitue
tellement on il y a la la pauvreté euh
fait prè question sur la population que
tout le monde
a envie en
fait comment dire de de s'arracher en
fait les opportunités les personnes
riches peuvent se permettre ça mais les
personnes qui sont pauvres qui n'ont pas
le les moyens de payer despôts de vin
malheureusement ils doivent attendre
longtemps et on n'est pas sûr s'ils
obtienent leur passeport ou pas Malon on
continue avec toi j'ai question pour
Solen pourquoi sont-elles parties dans
deux pays différents nigina est allée en
Allemagne parce qu'elle avait de la
famille
elle avait une tente en Allemagne et
donc très souvent les Afghans comme tous
les peuples du monde qui sont forcés à
l'exil ils se rapprochent ils font tout
pour se rapprocher de de pays où ils ont
des attaches familiales pourquoi sopia a
pas cherché à rejoindre nigina en
Allemagne parce que nous on pouvait pas
on ne pouvait pas du tout influencer le
voilà le consulat allemand alors que il
se trouve que on en tant que française
en tant française on pouvait appuyer la
demande de de sopia ok vachement ici
puis en fait c'était bien que sopia soit
c'est bien que sopia soit là parce
qu'elle avait pas de famille en
Allemagne et que ici à Paris au moins on
l'avait autour de nous donc plutôt voyez
quand vous arrivez vous êtes mis dans
des dans enfin vous êtes on vous propose
d'être dans des centres qui s'appell des
centres de demandeurs d'asile qui en
général sont extrêmement Glo et
franchement ghetto et du coup elle était
à la maison donc c'était c'était plus
doux pour elle d'arriver comme ça elle
était avec mon fils elle av un petit le
petit Margot enfin voilà ça normalisait
un petit peu le ça normalisait un peu
l'arrivé du coup elle a pu commencer en
douceur et elle a trouvé un boulot comme
ça en en 3 mois et maintenant elle gagne
sa vie elle est voilà elle est très
autonom alors pour vous Madame Daoud
quelle est la condition de vie des
hommes qui ne sont pas Taliban et y y
a-t-il des hommes qui se battent pour le
droit des femmes h alors je pense que
euh le choc d'arrivé des talibans a fait
que certaines hommes qui né qui ne sont
pas d'accord avec les talibans euh ont
tellement peur parce que à chaque fois
quand une femme quelque fait quelque
chose c'est aux hommes à leurs pères et
frères que les talibans vont s'en
prendre c'est-à-dire que ils vont punir
les hommes et c'est c'est seulement les
hommes qui peuvent aller dehors
travailler ramener euh je ne sais pas à
manger à la maison dans le foyer enfin
s'occuper euh des des enfants de la
famille et cetera donc beaucoup d'hommes
garde le silence et ça les déshumanise
aussi parce que nous on on leur on
attend les femmes afgans attendent que
les hommes afghans les soutiennent qui
qui les accompagnent dans leur combat
pour la liberté mais certaines hommes
sont rebelles ils vont rejoindre les
groupes de résistance par exemple d
début de l'arrivée des talibans par
exemple Ahmed Massoud qui est le fils de
commandant Massoud il a créé le l'armée
nationale de résistance il est parti à
Pancher àarab et enfin vers le bas
d'archan nord du pays il a commencé à
faire des des interventions en mode
guerriia pour pouvoir empêcher les
talibans ou au moins garder le contrôle
de certaines local éalité et province
sauf que ce Guera ou
C Front national de résistance n'est pas
vraiment soutenu par les pouvoirs
étrangers et aussi il y a au ZI je pense
il y a un autre front qui est comme le
Front national de résistance mais avec
d'autres modalités d'autres modes de
fonctionnement donc les gens qui les
hommes qui sont contre qui qui ont
accepté tous les risques vont rejoindre
ces groupesl notamment parmi eux on peut
trouver beaucoup de militaires et des
gens qui euh faisaient partie de de la
police ou de de l'ancienne l'armée
nationale mais aussi des des gens
normaux qui ne veulent pas euh vivre
sous la tyranie des talibans on va
terminer avec toi sa je voudrais que tu
poses ta dernière question à shakiba
s'il te plaît quel message faire passer
aux prochaines génération moi je pense
queil faut pas
s'arrêter de rêver euh il
faudrait vouloir la liberté et chaque
génération à sa propre perception et
envie de liberté ce que en tout cas moi
je souhaite c'est de pouvoir
transmettre aux prochaines
générations afghan de dire que nous
avons lutté nous avons vécu cette
situation cet effondrement et nous avons
pu se nous pouvions faire en tout cas
les femmes afghanes avec nos alliés
évidemment étrangères d'autres femmes et
que aujourd'hui euh au degré que nous
soutenons les autres luttes
internationales nous attendons aussi que
la communité internationale nous
soutienne dans ce lutte et dans ce
combat parce que nos destins sont liés
nous vivons sur la planète Terre il y en
a qu'un seul et que c'est c'est mieux de
vivre dans la paix et dans l'amour que
dans la guerre voilà la vie est courte
nigina et sopia peut-être qu'elles
verront cette émission j'espère on le
enverra en tout cas en tout cas on vous
transmettra le lien de cet échange donc
ell vont potentiellement vous regarder
qu'est-ce que vous avez envie de leur
dire en tout cas genre leur dire
qu'elles sont extrêmement fortes d'avoir
fait tout ça et que en fait en faisant
ça je pense elles ont inspiré beaucoup
d'autres femmes genre pas forcément
afghanes mais de de tout type de femme
ben du coup j'aimerais leur souhaiter
une bonne une bonne continuation et
aussi de profiter de la vie ouais voilà
en général et voilà on pense c'est la
même chose c'est qu'elles ont eu raison
de se battre et d'avoir eu raison d'être
enfin de persister de croire qu'elles
auraient pu être libéré puisqueau final
elles l'ont été et que j'espère elles
vont revenir pour pour s'occuper des
autres femmes de leur famille parce que
je pense qu'il y en a encore d'autres je
sais pas elles ont forcément des parents
et tout et j'espère qu'elles sont
repartis pour s'occuper d'elle en fait
toi tu esppères qu'elles reviennent dans
leur pays qu'elles reviennent en
Afghanistan non pas pour y vivre mais
juste pour venir en aide aux autres
femmes qui sont encore là-bas OK et je
pense que il y a dû avoir un truc comme
ça enfin elles ont dû repartir je pense
j'espère on va demander à Solen
peut-être non non elles ont pas du tout
elles sont pas du tout rentré elles ont
pas le droit en fait parce queelles ont
elles ont statut de réfugié maintenant
donc quand tu es réfugié tu peux pas
retourner on te prend le passeport de
ton pays natal donc elles y sont pas
retournées elles ont pas elles ont envie
de que leur famille sorte aussi oui ça
c'est sûr que les femmes de leur famille
sortent et soient protégé mais elles ont
pas ell elles ont pas envie je pense de
retourner en Afghanistan tant que les
talibans sont pas partis ou alors tant
que les talibans n'ont pas changé elles
ont très envie de vivre dans leur pays
mais pas un pays taliban donc je pense
qu'elles ont plutôt en tête de revenir
un jour enin vous leur poserez la
question mais de revenir quand quand ce
sera plus tranquille pour elle ouais on
va terminer l'émission là-dessus merci
infiniment à toutes les deux d'avoir
répondu à à toutes ces belles question
question merci aux professeurs qui ont
si bien préparé les élèves nous on se
retrouve très vite avec une nouvelle
classe et un nouveau documentaire parce
qu'il n'y a pas d'âge pour questionner
le monde et ses images salut les élèves
[Musique]
roir